مع رد الفعل الأولي من
المتحدث باسم رئيس السلطة الفلسطينية يبدو أنه سلبي ، يصف
هذه الخطة الحالية فكرة ورشة العمل الاقتصادية هذه
بأنها فكرة غير مجدية يقول إننا
خطة اقتصادية بدون أفق سياسي
لن تؤدي إلى أي
مكان بالحد الأدنى من
الرئيس الفلسطيني.
المتحدث يقول إن الحد الأدنى الذي
يحتاجون إليه ما
يريده الفلسطينيون قبل الانخراط في
المحادثات هو معرفة أن
هناك دولة فلسطينية يمكن أن
تكون هناك دولة فلسطينية على الأقل وأن
عاصمتها ستكون القدس الشرقية
و  المكون السياسي لهذه الخطة
التي أخبرنا بها البيت الأبيض هو
شيء يمكن أن يأتي في وقت لاحق من هذا
العام ، إنه طموح للغاية
ثقيل جدًا على فكرة كيف يمكن للاقتصاد أن
يرفع المنطقة ويمكنه أن ينهض
بحياة الفلسطينيين ولكن  ما
نسمعه من السلطة الفلسطينية
هو حقًا إبداء إعجاب بهذه النظرة النهائية ،
كان هناك مثل ورشة عمل  تم
ترتيب هذا في واشنطن العام الماضي في الولايات
المتحدة في آذار (مارس) لم نذهب إلى
أنهم فقدوا إيمانهم بالولايات
المتحدة باعتبارها وسيطًا دوليًا
بينهم وبين الإسرائيليين ، فقد
أشاروا إلى حقيقة أنه عندما كان الرئيس
ترامب في وقت متأخر  أعلنت 2017 إلى 10 ديسمبر 2017
أن القدس عاصمة
لإسرائيل قالت
إنها نقلت السفارة الأمريكية فعلاً السفارة الأمريكية من تل أبيب إلى
القدس وهو ما ينفي حقًا
قيام الولايات المتحدة  الموقف هنا للتفاوض أو
أن نكون مفاوضين قابلين للاستمرار هنا
وما سمعناه في الأسابيع الأخيرة أيضًا
من قادة السلطة الفلسطينية من
سفيرهم لدى الأمم المتحدة الذي قال إن
هذه الصفقة ستنتهي عند الوصول
وقبل يومين فقط في
لندن  قال وزير الخارجية إن هذه
الخطة لن تمنح أساسًا أي
سيادة ولا عدالة ولا استقلال
ولا حرية للفلسطينيين ، لذا فإن
الرسالة في الوقت الحالي التي تبدو أنها
تستهزئ بهذه الخطة NIC Robertson
CNN Abu Dhabi